dans tous ces frères arcens se doutait
de
dans le centre-est roland geffroy ton
absence mauvaise dans la nuit des temps
très courts year suit la prospère
fredonnant tout césaire ville basse
mazurkas et surtout vos niveaux au tout
beau tout bon et tout ça c'était encore
hier tu étais là prospère un donne en
tout 16 heures
diguine vaste matthew k et surtout
follow up tout beau tout bon et tout ça
[Musique]
pour les fleurs coupées dans les nuits
centre est
[Musique]
j'ai fait mon absence nous pèse
et dans la nuit centré
[Musique]
je vois des passants l'au delà
quel bonheur aibre chômeurs tu resteras
toujours le géant aux pieds de papier
l'éternité
tu avais une fois des passants lautner
quel bonheur des branches en main tu
resteras toujours le génome entier de
papier pour l'éternité
[Musique]
roland et jeffrey veux ton absence nous
pèse dans les fiefs ton absence pèse 1
[Musique]